shea was a local legend and his
unexpected passing at just 46 years old
was a shock to those he most inspired 8
news now reporter madison kimbrough is
live outside zappos tonight
to share a message from one person whom
shea deeply touched
madison
yes with so many unanswered questions
it's leaving us all
in limbo but we did uncover more details
and also spoke to a local las vegas
business woman who says that shea
was her inspiration just days ago we
learned that entrepreneur
and las vegas resident tony shea had
passed away
after he was hurt in a fire details of
how it started are still unknown but
according to real estate site redfin
this is the oceanfront home where it all
happened government records show it's
owned by one of shea's former co-workers
at zappos
rachel brown whether brown was inside
the home with shea is still unknown but
it has been reported that shea was with
his brother at the time of the fire
and while we all just want answers as to
what happened one las vegas business
woman who owns
see us now staffing an employment agency
shares how he personally
impacted her life i literally was
sitting with tony shea
talking to him because i went to where
he was speaking at
um downtown and then he got me an
appointment with his partners
for me to go look at their i guess their
shared space that they had
lauren allen described shea as down to
earth friendly and willing to help
as she was starting out in her business
ventures you know he touched my heart in
the sense where
he taught me about culture how do you
want to be known to the people you work
with
and work they work for you right so
that's what i mean by culture
she knows that shea had an impact on so
many and that he will be greatly missed
i'm only one person he touched there are
thousands and thousands of people that
this man touched
he gave so much to our community
shea was 46 years old and we will keep
you updated throughout the week the
latest on
this story reporting live from zappos
madison kimbrough 8 news now